today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza I want to say this when
I travel I wear like some sweatpants and
sometimes they're not they're not
typical sweatpants they're more of like
kind of a swaggy kind of you know bulky
kind of sensual Couture kind of you know
a body bag for each one of my legs if
you will and those are made by layered
layered is 100% organic cotton they're
made in America with American fabric
they're classic style modern fit and
they're direct-to-consumer no middleman
so if you know some of them you look
outside of a building you see somebody
out there loitering around and they
might be selling jewelry or something
that ain't layered no middleman no
loitering
it's direct-to-consumer they pass the
savings on to their customers and I'll
be honest when I'm traveling them on the
go
I love layered it just makes me feel
it's on me but it's not on me it's not
bugging me I don't like my clothes to
feel like they gripping up on me like I
used to like they acting like we used to
know each other better and stuff and
they trying to get at me so go to layer
USA and use code Theo th EO at checkout
for 10% off
that's promo code Theo at checkout for
10% off we are grateful to have support
and today's episode is brought to you by
AK Dion Jim Beach and travel equipment
act Aeon towels they are ultra compact
and made with premium microfiber
material they absorb three times their
own weight so you might have this hitter
right here and look you roll that bad
boy out next thing you know you
hide-and-go-seek or whatever you want
you have a beach towel you have a place
where you can eat on if you've been
hiking you can set this out and get the
job done right there on the edge of a
mountain if you need to conceive a child
or slice up a little cut of ham or
anything you want
they absorbs three times their weight in
liquid more than three times smaller and
they dry three times faster than bulky
cotton towels each towel is treated with
silver ions to prevent the growth of
bacteria
she ain't got to worry about seeing this
thing later and have it have a little
bit of molded up or a little bit of
mother nature's boogers in it you feel
they come in two sizes full-size beach
towel and gym towel that is acti on Jim
Beach and travel equipment you can go to
get acti on GE t AC t EO n.com right now
and use code theo 5-0 that's th zero
five zero at checkout for 50% off all
towels plus free shipping on us orders
at get AK t on GE ta c te o in.com use
code theo th zero five zero for 50% off
what's up guys
before I say today's yes I'm gonna let
you know I'll be performing coming up in
Charlotte Washington DC Salt Lake City
Toronto hold just hold a beat on getting
the Toronto tickets we're figuring that
out if you already have them you know
just not sure yet if that's going to be
coming to fruition and where else
Appleton Wisconsin
and Buffalo New York other places that I
will be coming to today's guest is it's
he's just one of a kind you know he's
like a tie it's like it's like the way
it's like it's all like all of mankind
got just just just put into one person
and he's like an Oracle to the great
beyond and and to the great ahead and
and he's one of the sweetest guys that I
know and one of the absolute funniest
gets you out of your seat straight up
savages Joey Coco Diaz is here with us
today
I want to know about that brother they
look like the one thing I definitely
want it to be you next time you come
across I don't love - you gonna come
dude I would love to go because so you
guys had to pass I know see you guys at
least got to skip some of the line all
right through like doctors
you guys must had a million people
trying to holler at you oh my god that
was crazy he's great it was great though
you know you don't know it'll save for
the podcast you don't really know how
good Disneyland is till you get that cuz
we're all cheap yeah and we're like 149
and I'm not going down there for the 49
miles mate but I mean you sit on a ride
to go I get it yeah
I'm safe did Eddie have children with
him or now yeah yeah their son oh yes
yeah his son and my daughter love each
other really yeah they love each other
they love each other blast what we all
go to the same restaurant on Wednesdays
cause kids eat free yeah I grow to love
is the spaghetti there yeah the pasta
restaurants the work should I believe
them no i but they like it and last week
we went and that's who was there yeah
great though when we all hung out mom
you know it's it's a different world man
that's crazy man and the kids are so
does your daughter know about the
podcast or anything she doesn't know
about that like what she kind of look at
it what the [ __ ] she knows yeah I don't
know what the [ __ ] she knows you know
she knows I got an office yeah he goes
over there she sees the microphones I
gotta hide the bong [ __ ] huh
she'll tell him if she wants to go to
you off his daddy and clean it so I'm
gonna come over and wipe it down and
have fun a big job and give her like
five hours yes and she just lost a tooth
you said on the way in you say your
daughter's lost a - [ __ ]
mind-boggling emotional is it for me it
was like I'm not you know I'm from a
different [ __ ] world yeah oh I
remember selling my teeth to some kid
that came dead through town yeah well
you good just on the street yeah your
baby teeth um I don't know if they were
baby or not there's someone might have
an adult by my mouth kept making
I needed them you know my mouth was just
producing [ __ ] this is like a silver
mine you know or like something you know
like my mouth was like do whatever we
got to do to sell something I'll [ __ ]
make as much enamel as you need
that's crazy I used to [ __ ] be
petrified as a dentist so I didn't go to
the dentist for like 20 years so I would
just do now and dental work now oh yeah
I got a bottle of Jack get some coke
[ __ ] up get a wrench and I'd go to
work dog and just get in there oh yeah I
pulled that wait so all these are all
fake yeah really those [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah Wow and then the day I did go
to the doctor I went through this Kevin
name Kevin says at DBS mm-hmm and bold I
said dad kidnapped a [ __ ] the
same day I got the teeth I got my
fillings done that morning I could see
that dental work will make you want to
[ __ ] kill you [ __ ] you know you know
that my attorney kept saying you should
use that the defense you know I'm like
no because I didn't want to kidnap this
dude we did for the temple yeah work
you're gonna say anyway before I wanted
this guy he was going down without the
dentist or not but that's the video
these days like you could do anything
man he could go to the dentist first and
then you're like yeah I was high on some
kind of yeah how do you know that I
don't you know what I could have made
the excuse up I just didn't want I
wanted to end it yeah I wanted to end it
at that age it's like I want to all this
just end at the start oh I knew I'd
[ __ ] up you have a lot of like amends
to make me you went through like when
you kind of started to kind of when you
kind of got out of this sort of
lifestyle I still make a bed really like
I still think of [ __ ] like oh you don't
want I should call that person and I
should write that one up like I was just
talking about my back I got a big beef
of my ex-wife you know I have a 27 year
old I don't talk - oh wow me and my wife
just just you know in life you we make a
few good [ __ ] decisions you know and
me getting married I was young I wasn't
really in love I was a [ __ ] criminal
you know so what made you get married in
like what was the thing you kind of did
honestly when you think kind of because
look I'm in that I'm in that some of
those situations like I you know I'll
worry about moving for
but knowing that I'm not ready sometimes
in certain environments you know well
you're never [ __ ] ready I mean you're
never ready for dick right there's no
handbook on marriage there's no handbook
on friendship there's no handbook on
life there's no handbook on anything you
know I remember a kid years ago there
was a phone guy at the store and one day
the [ __ ] the talent coordinator got
fired
they just made him the talent
coordinator Wow he didn't know nothing
about nothing
yeah he got fired six months later but
you just have to be ready there's times
that in life that I can't train you for
what's gonna happen
right and that's if you think about your
life I'm now old you know I'm 38 think
about your life that's most of your life
you've been
nobody could train you for what you
either fall apart them nervous breakdown
go see your psychiatrist or [ __ ] live
your life yeah
live your [ __ ] life because it's it's
it's very man it's so true man it's so
you have no idea how much exact timing
this is it literally I'm going with
therapist today at 7:00 and it's like
you know some things that's just like
I'm the sometimes I'm just afraid to
like maybe admit what the truth is to
myself and instead I'll get stuck in
some of these like therapies situations
because sometimes I feel like I know
what the truth is but it's hard
sometimes it's hard to know if your
instincts are reliable does that make
any sense like if you get an instinct if
it's true if it's legit or not or if
it's fear or if it's I had a friend I
have a friend that's the kiss of death I
love him with all my heart but every
decision he makes is a bad decision
hmm and I was thinking about it about a
month ago and I was thinking about when
I was in the same position at one time
in my life everything I did was a bad
decision I mean I was to kiss at that
yeah when I got out of prison and
everything I did get married everything
I did so I I consciously made a [ __ ]
decision to think about every decision
and not to do the first thing that came
to my mind Wow like I had to actually do
that right
that's um the bad idea like I would be
negative to be positive right because I
was doing everything wrong wrong so
before I do that I'm gonna [ __ ] my
little hot water
and do the other thing and I started
changing here because you have to come
to terms with yourself and go this ain't
working
yes sometimes you gotta realize it yes
manually you're not gonna make the best
maybe your instinct isn't the best of
decision maker yeah you know yeah this
morning I woke up and I saw something
about the The Nerdist exonerated on NBC
and all this stuff you know I don't know
who's accuser is or whatever do it look
Chris Hardwick got yeah but I was very
happy I've met Chris a couple times you
know he is what he is he's a sweetheart
of a guy but you can't we can't keep
this country was built on laws yeah that
you have to be judged by your peers and
but we're getting judgment by the
internet now yeah and that's not fair
that's not right that's not what this
was whole thing was about mm-hmm this is
about you say something like yeah I did
that all right give me the camera
give me the footage let's go yeah I
can't base everything on your [ __ ]
word that's why I don't go to therapy
right I used my podcast as therapy I
beat you to the punch
I'm gonna get it out there before you
could even get it out there I made the
[ __ ] story you all know story I'll
tell you I don't give a [ __ ] was 30
years ago to arrest me yeah beat me up
well you do land them at this point
there's not much you can do yeah I have
I do something positive and a mental
type away once a month yeah you do a lot
of stuff I do something like I just
reached out before the Netflix special
which you came out to mean you very much
yes great awesome mouth I reached out to
somebody who did me a solid when I was
16 years mmm and I didn't know the
amount of the solid that it was so I
[ __ ] on the solid you know saying yeah
and I live with that every day and we
kind of talk well I could see it in his
face
listen he has no reason to talk to me he
really doesn't right I caused havoc in
his house I caused havoc in his life and
I wrote him this long thing and I just
said listen if there's anything I could
do to come over to your house and talk
to your family just nobody wants to died
with this [ __ ] on there it
it's it's not such a big deal right was
a big deal then today it's not such a
big deal we all lived we all survived I
haven't heard back from him right
is it hard sometimes like for people
like do you find it because what do you
think it's one of the things that like
stops us turns up sometimes from being
the bigger man cuz sometimes like you
know like I want to be angry instead of
be grateful you know or I want to be you
know I don't want to reach out to some
you know like I still want to hold that
grudge like when you have those kind of
moments like how do you kind of get
through some of that you know instead of
being like well [ __ ] I could still hold
a grudge against this person but I'm
gonna do this instead you know TJ
English he did the podcast with me and
Rogan and he said it's 30 40 years
experience dealing with Cuban people
were always very vindictive hmm you know
the book he wrote about that guy was
about a godfather you know about a crime
Godfather
mm-hmm but the guy used to kill people
himself like that's unheard of like with
episode 8 of The Sopranos they were
thinking in cancer were surprised I
think after episode 7 they really HBO
did not want Tony killing somebody yeah
because a mob boss always sends an
underling hmm but but chase wanted to
make this point so he had Tony kill him
with this guy battle you know I'm very
vindictive I will get you yeah I will
lay down like a [ __ ] dog now wait
years I've done it the people already
you know dying I'd done it to
[ __ ] already Wow sit in the
bush for years
you know that's a horrible way to live
though yeah that's a hole I'm the king
of it cuz I'm gonna do it it's because
that's just starting you all the time
running in the background like an open
window on the internet like it's just
sitting there running like there's
somebody right now yes in Burbank yeah
but I want to go over there and throw my
the [ __ ] window every morning when I
wake up and the other thing that stops
me is my family my daughter what I'm
doing right now because he's a piece of
[ __ ] yeah he's been a piece of [ __ ] to a
lot of people yeah a lot of comedians
and I knew it when I but guess why I
don't throw him out the window
hmm because I did business with him and
I knew it going in and he was a piece of
[ __ ] Wow so shame on me my god I got
caught up in the smoke of the situation
now I have to pay for my sins but
get that [ __ ] eventually yeah
I'll give him a flat I'll put sugar in
his gas tank some along the line I'm
[ __ ] some up with saran wrap in his
gas tank
yeah he'll stall every 30 miles to 405
you know I'm the king of that [ __ ] never
worse I don't want to live there yeah I
don't want to be there you know like I
said two weeks ago I wrote a letter to
my ex-wife mm-hmm like and I said all
the things I did wrong
yeah but I took the letter and I lit it
on fire
Wow I don't want nobody getting that
letter I don't wanna go to jail yeah and
does she know all these things you said
no no no no no no I just wanted to know
you wanted in it I just wanted to know
where I [ __ ] up and how is your way
what I had done you know it's oh man I'm
afraid it's it's so crazy hearing you
say some of that because sometimes it's
like if I were yet the real the truth
sometimes it's like I'm afraid I'd be
probably afraid even [ __ ] read it all
to myself you know oh when I read it
when you read something like when I
write a story about me robbing somebody
I get my little iPad and I'm right then
I giggle and then I read it reading it
[ __ ] my world up yeah like reading it
[ __ ] my world up for it out because it
changes the perspective of a camera into
perspective what you're thinking what
you're reading is two different things
it's a little harder when I said I I
jumped through his window and all that
[ __ ] you know it seems a little a little
bit rougher but I it's been great I've
been trying to you know ever since I
have the family I just want to shed some
of this [ __ ] snakes again yeah you
know that's why I don't like any of
these accusations from people lately
you can't I can't come back to Cleo I
said that when we were going to
university of [ __ ] Texas one night
you touch my dick I can't say that now
yeah that's crazy
I can't do that now twenty years way
that's not right to you it's not right
not right to me let me call play on
Blakeley oh man couple years ago I felt
a little threatened by you in that room
we're doing blow and you asked me to
show me your monkey yeah [ __ ] we don't
blow it before you know that yeah yeah
well why the coke you suck you're gonna
fix the phone yeah you're gonna fix a
faucet in your mouth and the reason why
I don't like this cuz I have a life
right that's the thing I know I've
changed the person I know I don't see
the [ __ ] I used to see yeah
and when I see it now if you know if I
was I would go into buildings like this
when I was 21 I put a suit on dog mm-hmm
and I'd walk past reception and I walk
into a business building like this and
I'd pick the third floor
and I just go from door to door looking
for Tony Smith Wow
Tony Smith there no there's no Tony what
were we looking for
I thought it was 303 yeah oh no no no
maybe check the fourth floor you how
many times I'd open up a door and
there'd be a purse sitting there or your
wall or something and you went to the
bathroom and let your wall yeah and I
would just take a walk to be 500 bucks
and I'd walk out the building and I was
good for the day yeah I did that for
years I would walk into a building and
I'm looking for you did we used to do
that - he said go through the
neighborhood at night and we'd steal
everybody's [ __ ] car radios right but
then here was why I did it there that
first you know we did it because we
wanted a radio for our own car but you
only can put like one radio in your own
car so then I got out of a back seat
with like nine radios in it you know all
the [ __ ] it sitting there but then
here's a lot started to do it because
then I would see people drive down the
street and be furious that they don't
have any music so then that will [ __ ]
make me laugh so hard brother see
somebody driving and this one do started
singing his own songs every day he had
no radio mr. crazy I never got into
robbing cars cost Barry love buddy
we used to rob car stereos but at one
point cars started putting a device in
it that if you stole the stereo wouldn't
work in another car I think especially
Subaru I can tell you what problem I
first started working for Subaru it was
1986 it was really I was living in
Boulder and I was a detailer but I
became friends with the manager's name
was Peter Pinto real street guy and one
day he's like why do you wash cars do
you like one of the best-selling just
property I can buy [ __ ] from you and he
goes just come over on a Monday and see
if you like it and I came over on a
Monday so three cars and made a thousand
bucks
at that time I used to work 60
hours a week the like washing I think it
was 860 a month they would pay me again
you made in a day I'd make in a day
selling cars now when I borrowed 500
from my girlfriend's mother and I went
and bought you know three jackets tree
pair pants a pair of shoes and bail and
I went and [ __ ] knocked and [ __ ]
dead but I thought I was making like
seven to ten grand a month
mmm that's my first four months in 1987
going to school seven grand a month
Subaru's selling ten cars a month but
you could've been there you gonna check
from them you're gonna check from the
Subaru but the lot man
drove like a [ __ ] like an expensive
BMW and I'm like how can a [ __ ] lot
man sell you know have a BMW I mean what
kind of white man make you know the year
went by I said a loyal employee you know
I got to a few arguments there I
threatened the [ __ ] break the car
with an axe window if they didn't pay me
and [ __ ] like that but the cops came in
one day this was a crazy place where I
worked it was called Crouch Subaru yeah
Krauts and that's German or ouch they
have their out son today they are you
gonna get [ __ ] robbed at some Azia
Oh uch they anunnaki restored today yeah
a couple of Acura stores but in those
days that Subaru store was a [ __ ]
accommodate like it was economy and they
didn't have a lot of Subarus if people
who know what that was ya know in
Colorado
seriously number one car it's not more
cards it used to be Burt Subaru well the
number one super dealer in the world
Wow they did 500 new Subarus or a
[ __ ] month or something and then we
were like number eight in the district
but one day the cops came and they
arrested this [ __ ] lock knob yeah he
was running a scam at the gym hmm but
what we also didn't know what is that
after you sold a car he would talk to
you for five minutes about your car and
he would upset you how he's selling [ __ ]
so this [ __ ] was taking the
stereos out of the GL ten sedans they're
not and putting in your shitty car so
all these people paying 20 grand for
these high-end cars and the radio like
an AM radio uh-huh and broke he did it
to every fight like when he got arrested
he had been doing this
years like people were buying that kind
of money Tata mother he was selling rims
tires then a cop came in again one guy
and surrounded the building because we
had a salesman I used to rob banks at
lunchtime oh wow his name was Carlos
Valverde a great idea and he would kick
mine kids nine [ __ ] kids he had with
the same wife he had been married like
30 [ __ ] years Abba neck [ __ ] as well
30 years he was like 22 managers Coveney
forget this guy one day the [ __ ] cops
came and surrounded the building he was
[ __ ] robbing banks is lunchtime him
and four other guys would [ __ ] get
Clarke I mean it was [ __ ] crazy
then I got in trouble there like this
car dealership was a professional great
sitcom everybody's stealing from
everybody
there was a guy in there that was in
probation because he robbed banks huh
and then and he was he just got a jail
doing 20 years for robbing banks the
manager was a biker that would work six
months of the year yeah I cut his hair
and shave and he was a great salesman
mm-hmm then the other half of the year
he was a biker hmm didn't do no drugs he
hated drugs and he hated the smell of
vinegar Wow
so when I didn't want him there I would
come in and I buy a bottle of white
vinegar but I take a cap and put in the
corner of his office and spill it and
he'd be in the office within minutes
he'd be like it's no bigger and he
[ __ ] leaned I used to get Coke
bindles and tie like a fish wire tool
mm-hmm I throw them on the floor by him
and I'd roll my CD [ __ ] trying to
step on it I had a great time that
sounds so much fun but it's so funny
because what I learned that year I still
do time right like all the things I
learned about selling cars and how you
should be a Salesman like I still use
those principles today mmm like that
they would kept me alive in the comedy
game yeah when you're armed so you you
said that your daughter lost a tooth
like what's that kind of like so like
what is like is it hard to
go from like you know being like is it
hard to switch into like a dad mode like
did you ever worry that it would be hard
to switch into like a dad mode or is it
just kind of naturally happening because
I you know like sometimes you know
especially as a comedian is kind of like
the center of attention you know
sometimes whether we want to be or not
you know and then like have your
daughter be the center of attention is
it different like is it as like us is it
unique or anything what's that like I've
had like five lives man yeah so like I
leave here now I go over the hill I pick
her up the corridor from camp and I take
a little hit and we tie and then I got a
half hour in between Muay Thai and
swimming yeah I sit there for a [ __ ]
hour and sit with her and then from
there we go to dinner tonight cuz it's
Wednesday night so spaghetti night so
it's spaghetti night it's and does she
like if she's in the pool you know
you're just watching her she just it's
like all the dads know yeah you know and
I'm very fortunate because a lot of
people are the pool of moms right I
could go with my wife all night you know
the way I look and I got a second chance
of being a day Wow
I [ __ ] up the first time so now I do
it to the tee I'm the type of guy have
you give me a second chance or something
that's it whatever the past was was the
past next time I'll do it to the [ __ ]
letter yeah and it's all that's going on
right now my life is very important like
every aspect of it the balance I have we
show up on yourself every day walk about
I give a [ __ ] about my family yeah we
got to feed our family we got to eat and
we got to act like a family if not we're
gonna I can we end up like an LA family
yeah force then I got a 16 year old wife
and I don't want that I did that already
yeah I did that already I want a family
I want to go home at night so I enjoy my
comedic life mm-hmm I love my podcast
life yeah you know I love going through
the storm bumblin to you guys I know
it's so much fun
last night was someone in the parking
lot is sticking your fingers up
somebody's ass yeah you're talking about
this and then I went and got pizza Joe's
my brother I was Sicilian slice for Lee
and his buddy and they waited for me by
their open mic so we sell [ __ ] latte
well 30 eaten pizza
talk this [ __ ] and people pulling on
going Joey what's happening
and we're talking about black dick and
[ __ ] how that I am it's funny cuz
alone yeah the chick she like black dick
[ __ ] she like the banana mist around the
dick got a black guy pulls up it's funny
I was just talking about black people he
came oh we started tell him about banana
dicks I mean when I told Bobby 12:30
just talking and then I go home and I
wash my hands I pee you know check on
the kid and I walk in her room tiptoe
yeah
and I turned the turtle off that's doing
like this psychedelic it's crazy it's
loose um yeah so now I turned this other
thing off and then I give her a kiss
yeah you know God bless you and and then
I walk to my office and there I am
smoking dope yeah two minutes later and
that you know so it's like I have my
life
yeah in between they're all going on at
one you know I really respect that
father ship [ __ ] like I don't get highly
like if I get hired before like swimming
or something I do Listerine I changed my
shirt up advisee memorize yourself like
at least a problem yeah I show up like a
problem show up like [ __ ] yeah
looking like Chiefy you're not having a
kid daughter hold the roach in her in
her swim back yeah in fact yesterday
morning I got up because she went to pre
care for us right she went to a - she
went to like freak mm-hmm and I was
against it but when my wife took me I
saw the kids I go what we're gonna do
keep her in the house on that right cuz
it's fun that you do art and stuff like
that they give you interact with other
kids right that's a huge that's the
biggest thing yeah that's that's that's
the big thing that when I came from Cuba
I had a big problem I didn't speak the
language problem yeah I didn't speak the
language it had my father died so I was
like Vito when he caught ya you ever see
The Godfather to him when Vito came he
was like a half a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he was like singing songs at the IMS he
was like saying hey he's like one of
those guys going through my neighborhood
no radio yeah with no radio yeah and
that was me I was damaged goods I was
damaged goods but my mom had me in an
adult world because right she didn't
believe in daycare so here I am with her
at the track I'm at the bar with her
that she owned yeah but you're at the
laundromat you learning about everything
that didn't do
didn't do me no favors right yet showed
me the world but a little slowed me back
it took me years to it took it out there
I was took already childhood how was it
single child
yeah so that don't help me this so you
don't know how to chair you don't know
how to do you get jealousy issues and
the kid is around your mom so I haven't
learned to deal with all that with me
I wanted her listen man let's [ __ ] be
honest as men let's be [ __ ] your mom
was hot no my mom was a [ __ ] dirty
[ __ ] oh sorry about oh it's okay you've
got a seven or eight you know a woman
has to fight hard in this world oh yeah
okay it's just the way it is ladies I'm
not here to tell you why or how it's the
way it's always been it's a hard so it's
a tough time I hide serve against a
woman from day one I'm trying to shorten
those odds if I could get her from nine
to one odds to seven to three
yeah I did my job as a dad amen I love
ass filling in those void see I thought
being a dad was buying a kid at $22,000
car no at 25 when I had my kid I thought
that that's what having a child was
having a child is when dog my phone's
ringing I don't give a [ __ ] that ringing
and I'm on the floor with her join
crayons every night yeah like every
night her and I sit together and we get
crayons and she yells at me why don't
you use markers like this I'm [ __ ]
old school I pray on this [ __ ] you know
the same I would cry out like a
[ __ ] and while I'm doing that
crowd and thinking about my life I'm
looking at her and I'm thinking about
the [ __ ] I didn't do as a kid but that's
everything that second chance when I get
home we demo she says her prayers even
though I'm talking about either [ __ ]
all day yeah up in that [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] and all this [ __ ] that comes out of
my mouth then at 6 o'clock I'm this guy
that says prayers at the table yeah and
where she take the elbows in favor and I
talk to her in Spanish oh I like that if
I say or you can top my son I'll say it
or I give up my son how was school today
oh and God boy so whatever I say to her
in English level on it and even if she
don't
she'll on the [ __ ] stand me as she
gets it what are some things that she
does that you notice is like you inside
of her that must be kind of cool honesty
like uh something like a moment in your
kid when they like maybe they laugh a
certain way or they look a certain way
or they do something like you know when
you see like you in it's like you don't
tuck him out come ya know there's a
couple things I see already I see that
she likes her a long time yeah this
times we walk in from doing something
she's like later and this time I go hey
I want to be alone right now
now I hurt my feelings but she gets red
I see that Cuban oh wow yeah so that
human blood is good but it's bad at the
same situations for I want to hold it
yeah it's more of a soup so I brought
him into jiu-jitsu about two months ago
mm-hmm and she fell in love with the
dude cuz my daughter's gonna be a little
dirty [ __ ] I love it at that but she
loves men and I wanted that yeah I'd
wanna like I bring her around guys so
she'd never scared she'd never
intimidated oh I like that my mother was
a bookmaker so she worked with men my my
mother walked into a room and it
respects you got ferment Wow it wasn't a
respect that she got because she had big
tension because she laid the law down in
that room yeah I came from a very
interesting back there that I didn't
know when my mother was 16 her and her
sister went to a dancing Cuba mm-hmm and
my sister my my mother couldn't find her
sister so she went outside and some guy
was raping her mm-hmm and my mother
broke a bottle and cut the guy stabbed
him from one side of his back to the
other he died Wow to get my mother out
of Cuba into the States so my mom went
to like caracal first corsage yeah miss
our first yeah we have a military base
there huge military base huge and then
she went to the States and then she went
back to Cuba with a fake identity and
everything disappeared so I look at my
daughter but I think about me and I know
that's in my blood
ten there thought that that's a
possibility well my
how to think quick I never knew the
story until she died wow she's fearless
I never knew the store I saw her in
action in fact yesterday it wasn't a
strong woman yes that was right the
[ __ ] thing mm-hmm
cuz I usually like when you go write
jokes sometimes you can't write jokes so
just sitting there licking a pen
I'll [ __ ] just write a story yeah I
don't like let's write it and I wrote a
story about me in karate and how I got
into karate karate because I played
hooky and I got hit in the head with a
lunchbox and I got stitches and then I
told my mother and the next day she
walked me to a black karate school all
black like people doing karate
oh yeah no 69 68 New York City as a
matter of fact you know Loranger orange
the guy that had ax Brazilian that hangs
out with all these guys is Eddie's black
belt oh wait is it uh not share what's
that guy's name he used to do hey uh uh
he goes to Brazilian accent his father
was my first karate Eve not even
thinking leave you don't talk about that
guy Eve that comes down sometimes he's
like friends with tape Fletcher and
those guys it's not him and Micky gall
he comes with those guys not him
no this guy's gonna have these black
belts Wow he has a shoulder Loranger
Loranger he's a black dude Lee makes
believe he's Brazilian capoeira boy
himself everybody his father was my
first black belt and his father would
walk around with a [ __ ] wooden sword
and hate yeah there was no gay and I got
kicked in the stomach one time and got a
wind knocked out of me huh and I'm like
I'm not going back at my mom grabbed my
shoes you don't go back in time a kick
in the stomach 50 [ __ ] back in there
that's no big deal I kicked one time he
would make you run on the streets with
your gear on barefoot mmm in 1968 you'd
be running past all your friends and
then the next day you go to school and
your friends like a karate man yeah come
on show some karate and [ __ ] so then you
be put on the spot Khan you kind of had
to respect your art I was yeah show your
arm to your friends and you had to
dinner then you decide for yourself to
our respect to my heart am I gonna show
it or what am I gonna do in this moment
that's why I love the martial arts so
much because at that time I was so
[ __ ] up but they brought me into
something I used to get bullied by this
kid Rudy the Haitian mmm-hmm he was a
Haitian kid
yeah Haitians can be wild man it's risky
50 shot every time with the head this is
the sixties in New York I don't even
know what a Haitian is yeah but the
whole neighborhood called him relation
and he was about my age and he would
beat me up like once a month or whatever
and one day I got the karate down I let
this [ __ ] up jack I lit him up
with kicks some [ __ ] double dragon I
got him with like 20 kicks to the
stomach and [ __ ] and then the next time
I fought him his father came downstairs
and grabbed my arms and pinned me and
let him hit me his father took me
upstairs cheatcode and my mother would
wake up in the mornings take me to
school but my mom would have a bar so
huge she wouldn't go to bed till 4:00 in
the morning so she would do all this
[ __ ] and come home and take a half a
little nap and this one particular day
he came upstairs knocked on my mom's
door which big mistake yeah my mom
opened the door what's going on he's
like the next time your son hits my son
I'm gonna hit him away at you and my mom
got a [ __ ] kitchen knife and chased
him up the stairs I was like a little I
was like five dan I was like crying
mom's gonna get there and also my mom
came down holding the knife said that
[ __ ] little [ __ ] with you again
and we went inside but the lady next
door had seen everything that went down
in the apartment everybody know yeah law
it was the 70s
there was no camera and Americans shut
that [ __ ] mouth there was no rats you
were not allowed to talk to the police
you were raised not to talk to the
police yeah I'll never forget like ten
minutes a the cops knocked on the door
they had my mom the hallway they turned
her around they were about to arrest her
he kept saying that my mother had a
knife and the little old lady came out
with her wit [ __ ] we call those two
knitting and probably knitting across or
something yeah rosary beads yeah she
goes I saw the whole thing she didn't
have a knife and that was it she had a
spoon
she was stirring coffee isn't that right
and my mom goes yeah see in Spanish the
cops like all right let it go and my mom
was telling Rudy's father in Spanish
that want my valuable to all this [ __ ]
and a week later Rudy's family moved
from the building mm-hmm we never saw
the Haitians again ha ha that's didn't
not with your mom being so tough was it
like did was it tough to feel like
affection from her because sometimes
like my mom's a hard worker right my mom
delivered you know she's a delivery
woman you know she delivered newspapers
when I was a kid she delivers magazines
now she's always had a [ __ ] van you
know
now she's got my her husband he's a salt
I'm we didn't even know he's in the van
he's with her every day you're [ __ ]
bouncing to the [ __ ] fantasy she had
to get a [ __ ] ii seatbelt install for
who cuz he [ __ ] what kind of sleaze
getting little he was slip out of her
house she's got him just basically in a
[ __ ] straitjacket just bouncing
around there's no clue where he is I was
delivering [ __ ] news on wheels every
day you know I think he's about 90 you
know mom still does it dude and here's
the worst part brush she got a good deal
on this van right my mom likes a good
deal and she got a good deal on Sven has
no wit not other side or back foot knows
brother so her [ __ ] GPS is the Lord
brother she just [ __ ] bouncing but
she's out there delivering all these
things man and move she just she won't
not work you know like I could tell her
like look you know I you know I give her
some money every month every month but
she wouldn't have anything else to do
you know it's like her identity but then
for me it was hard to like for me that
kind of mom was hard to connect with you
know because that she just had you know
she for me I looked at my mom is like
the mom and the dad I didn't realize
when I was a kid but you know do you
find it was tough to like have an
emotional like a mother-son connection
when your mom is like such a has to be
such a bravado you know what I'm saying
kinda I grew up without a dad I had a
stepdad my mom was tough yeah mom was
very tough in today's world there would
be light abuse but I'm saying yeah same
I'm thankful yeah I'm saying everything
she did because my mom prepared me for
the world today I'm not raising my
daughter I'm preparing my daughter just
in case something happens to me hmm
my mom did a great job but she left a
lot of gaps and that's where the damage
came in right so what I did differently
is I write all the damage down I write
for my daughter so I write every couple
days what I'm feeling what my thoughts
are kind of like Jax teller on sons of
anarchy yeah so if something does happen
she she knows what's going on she has
all the [ __ ] answers
never shall know the true you know I
won't tell my daughter Mac Amelia I'll
show her cuz I'm not she's gonna want to
be a [ __ ] coming from this stage
right don't tell them I don't even like
the pre-k teacher the other day said
have your daddy help you write it but
it's got to be clean I don't want that
[ __ ] don't tell her because it's gonna
be all right for her to be the class
clown right I don't want to be the class
yeah my mom dog made me fight my mom
brought a girl home for me the first
time for the [ __ ] so this day I can look
you guys both in the eye and I don't
even know if I [ __ ] I think I passed
out from fear you know saying yeah I
came on a girl once in this [ __ ] and
then lied about it made her then I got
so scared I [ __ ] left out of my own
window my room I was too embarrassed to
walk through my own [ __ ] house it was
a party at my house not his [ __ ] left
bra and there's all these people just
driving silently up and down the street
[ __ ] sing it in their cars and I'm
like this is a [ __ ] crazy world man
do I sound like I got a little bit of
flavor up in my throat well I just might
that cuz that's it that's because I'm
having a couple little handfuls a little
little paws full of that lakeside maple
mmm daddy got that hitter right there
lakeside maple specializes in trail mix
baked with P m/s pure maple syrup that's
right
original spicy and ginger chai are the
three different flavors my favorite is
the original all of their mixes are made
by hand and they're fans of this podcast
so get in there and try out the best
trail mix that everyone thinks is
granola but it's not it's trail mix I
also try that new tmb that trail mix
butter baby
go to lakeside maple calm and use code
Theo th EO at checkout for 15% off
that's promo code Theo at checkout for
15% off lakeside maple get that mix
lakeside maple dot-com use code Theo
about to have me a little powerful the
legend collection just drops and you can
see one just landed right on my head
this is a hood hat and these hats are
specific man you want a hat now that
represents your block your field your
alley your neighborhood you know and
that's what these are this one says
Death Valley
from Clemson Clemson and that is uh with
the Clemson colors that that that orange
in that purple you can get Death Valley
for LSU as well you can get jordan-hare
for you Auburn Tiger fans Davis Wade the
head says Davis Wade for Mississippi
State
they got one that just says Blacksburg
for vitek big house for Michigan the
horseshoe for Ohio State
and the Grove for Ole Miss and these
things are swaggy these things are
spikey these are the ones that you know
you know these swaggy hitters want to be
wearing so you can go to Hood hat
usa.com and use promo code hood USA for
20% off
that's Hood hat calm use promo code hood
USA for 20% off or follow on instagram
at hood hat USA get that hat ah it's a
[ __ ] crazy world man and what we do I
think of the world our hen listen have
you ever thought of what we do have you
ever gone to an open mic and seen a
bunch of guys that I've been in for four
years and it takes you right back to it
and going like damn what made me stick
with this yeah with this abuse at the
four-year market you're not really a
feature you start to emcee your home
club hates you your friends go to
Montreal you're like ah so worse you
know it's all these emotions that most
people can't hang most people listening
properly at 27 years I've seen a top ton
of people come and I see that ton of
people don't I've seen people that have
gone to gigs with that have
conversations they love comedy this is
what they do and a year later I go to a
commercial audition and there they are
in there with a camera going well you
know I was a little on the tough side
here like what are you talking about we
just did a gig together you were telling
me how yeah this is what I do this is
what we do yeah it chooses you after a
while I think this sport too like comedy
just chooses you like um I don't even
know like I don't even feel when I get
up anymore in the on the stage anymore
like I'm trying to make them laugh I
just feel like this is what I have
do to get through the day or the week
it's just like part of the week it's so
someone's like getting out of bed and
making coffee or something like I used
to feel up there like I was in this
moment where like okay I got a let's see
how this works and let's see how this
works and now I feel like I can finally
just kind of be up there you know did
you start to notice that it you got as
you got along in it like you can just
kind of the goal in the end is almost to
just kind of get get to the way you are
in front of your friends like you joke
around in front of your friends but when
you get onstage is this different
pressure but eventually it all comes all
the way back around where the whole
crowd just feels like you're in front of
your friends think of this word of words
I'm sorry the journey of emotion how
long have you been doing comedy for 15
so in those 15 years I want you to think
where your emotions were before you went
onstage when you started mmm your
emotions were when you get on stage now
it's [ __ ] two different [ __ ] world
yeah now three months ago I could look
these both in the face when you came to
see me in Vegas yeah I'm gonna tell you
[ __ ] I was damaged goods yeah
because it happens is the human brain
and sometimes our brain gets [ __ ]
Friday oh yeah everything not to mention
the reefer not to mention is being a
father not to mention a thousand
variables but guess what [ __ ]
I'm back now yeah how many Y's I'm back
because I got lost I watched John
Mulaney and I thought I wanted to be
John Mulaney he was a great [ __ ]
comic yeah great writer but guess what
I'll never be gentle Mulaney and I'll
never be the old one yeah and guess
what's even better
Silvan will never be John Mulaney don't
that would be Joe Diaz why cuz he's
[ __ ] Theo von yeah and Joe Diaz Joe PS
and you know what once I put that
together like I'm brand new again yeah
like I feel like I'm 20 [ __ ] eight
now when I'm on stage like now you got a
[ __ ] problem last night I ate up that
fandom you can't what every fight you
insane the main room I [ __ ] came out
there last night if I would have had a
xanax in a seven minute mark I would've
had to take it can you feel my heart
ready to jump out of my chest and that's
what family is all about
yeah when you still feel that in your
balls that's what it's all about for
months I wasn't feeling the business
part got them yeah the business person
sucks dick that the [ __ ]
business of that and the tickets you
know what I don't give a [ __ ] you don't
want to come see me no [ __ ] come see
me I'm still gonna do what I do on stage
I'm gonna be crazier than ever
crazy enough I don't give a [ __ ] about
society or how [ __ ] and what you can
say we and say that's got nothing to do
with me bro I'm a comic and I'm sick and
[ __ ] tired what's going on
no more safety net yeah you know I was
making excuses up to you I'm not gonna
let the commies throw no more because I
can't work out new material too bad
work it out the county store work it out
if you bomb you Bob yeah that's what
Mitchell intended that place to be but
in my head I'm like well they pay $25 I
can't bomb [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I gotta
take a chance on something type rope if
not I just become one come from eating
robot and that's what I was becoming aa
comedic scared robot no man no no more
if I'm in the middle of the bit and I
think there's something that happened
I'm dropping it and if I forget the bit
so be it so be it
I'm going where my mind takes me now my
balls are connected to my heart are
connected to my brain and that's it from
now on I'm 55 what I got five six years
left to do time before you too old and
ugly to get on stage and people like
Joey let it go
my mom will drive you to [ __ ] gigs to
your life so over comedy now like the
Netflix special all that stuff was like
I said like this thanks kid
yeah I'm like I'm done there is this
skin that comes in with the industry it
is yes it's not cool for guys like us no
no it's not your thing don't [ __ ]
tell me what to say don't tell me not to
what no not the [ __ ] to say number
two I went to bro and I when I bought
every piece over the year I know the
last couple of years you know with the
podcast we have great families that
we've developed huh yeah they know my
love for comedy so people started
bringing me albums
Bob Newhart out oh wow and [ __ ] Lenny
Bruce live from Carnegie Hall and
[ __ ] they brought me all the Richard
Pryor almost a good one bicentennial
[ __ ] and the good was something I said
or you know the [ __ ] crazy those are
raw Richard Pryor Wow I forced myself to
put them back
I'm turntable [ __ ] 5 videos yeah [ __ ]
watch your [ __ ] specials I mean think
about it in your head put it on video
look how they did it they would do a
tour and take the bit the best way came
out you could hear the bill end and then
it start all over again
so the albums were brilliant yeah when
are we doing that yeah where aren't we
doing it I don't want a special ever
again
yeah ever again do I want to shoot a
special you know it's a vowel it's just
out yeah I want you to listen I want
them to hear the glasses I want them to
hear the [ __ ] breathing I want them
that's what comedy is to me yeah the
specials they forgot how to shoot
Oh 100% they forgot it [ __ ] don't
look at Lenny Bruce everybody tries to
be avant-garde now they're showing you
the audience they want to show you a
fire that just show the stand-up from
the waist to the head doing stand-up
yeah don't show me the [ __ ] audience
we just act like I watched somebody
special
he was bombing the audience was that
wasn't laughing yeah and you can hear
like this laughter if you laugh you go
like this you move back and forth when
you laugh
this audience was stiffer than [ __ ] yeah
you can hear the laugh track you know
Netflix is about to drop about 47
especially that means nobody's gonna get
to watch and we're all gonna be caught
in a mess yeah what were you gonna do
it's almost like Netflix doesn't even
care people watch him it's just that
they want to say that they own it you
know I'm saying it in a weird way a lot
of networks have become like and I'm not
likening this to slavery at all but
they've become that's what it's almost
about it's like how can I own a piece of
this person as opposed to like how can i
push this art you know like I find that
with some spec it's just like I don't
know it just sometimes I'm like I I want
to be freer than that you know I want to
be freer than that and like you know I
mean I feel so fortunate like you know
just to be like even you know fighter
and the kid guys and you know to be able
to be friends with guys like you
and and Joe and and you know just
becoming better friends with some of
these guys where it's like I feel like
we're in this free space you know it's
like we don't have to dude I hate it for
years man I used to not be able to be
myself in this town man and it made me
feel like what
you know there was something here that
made me [ __ ] where I would like I had to
like try and act like the second best
friend on a sitcom or something and it
was just man I just hated it and I hate
it
asked you in the [ __ ] horse you know
what the best thing somebody says to you
is be yourself
yeah and we never understand what that
is let's be myself me exactly what I
just told you yeah you just said it you
the goal of comedy is to appear to them
like you're talking to your friends yes
when I talk to my friends what do I talk
and they love it do I talk about
intelligence stuff do I try to make
believe now I talk about the filthiest
whatever the [ __ ] is on my mind and talk
about whatever some [ __ ] is racist I'm
not racist yeah some [ __ ] you gotta say
it with color or not it's not gonna
[ __ ] come to [ __ ] out right yeah you
know some [ __ ] would living in this
don't come to the show yeah you know
what man when I came here 20 years ago I
really really really wanted to be on TV
we all do mm-hmm but now after you do
this and we have this freedom really you
want to go work at CBS and have somebody
come up to you and go excuse me but the
word is that instead of and yeah does it
make a difference ain't nobody watching
this shitty [ __ ] show anyway yeah
doesn't make a difference and of that
they pay some lady to come up to you and
tell you oh the word is cars who gives a
[ __ ]
give us a [ __ ] you know so yeah it's
ridiculous right you know that's why I
always looked at comics early on hmm
when in the 70 and 80s and 90s a lot of
comics ended up and Rehab the wrong TV
yeah you're fighting it with yourself
it's a comic a real comic should have a
hard time on network TV yes well they
mean I've just had an Anatomy at a lunch
with an executor days a friend of mine
and we're talking about that I said well
you'll get so many [ __ ] writers and
give him these shows these people aren't
entertainers like I wouldn't watch half
these [ __ ] you know they're not even
real they're just writers like why do
y'all keep putting writers in front of
can't like I'd rather watch you know
like that girl punky Johnson that works
at the Comedy Store black girl in the
kitchen with the long dredge hard core
[ __ ] lesbian bra you know I'm saying
solo
she's so lesbian two years she's gonna
[ __ ] to sprout a car
can what I'm saying she's ready to party
you know but I would watch her she's
only been doing comedy maybe five or six
years right she's from Louisiana I'd
watch her more than I'd watched some
[ __ ] writer and it's just because
she's at least a it you know I just used
her as an example but she's just a part
she's a thing you know she's
entertaining it's like like that's one
thing I like about Sebastian like at
least Sebastian's [ __ ] entertaining
you know like Bosch is very he's a he
you watch him and you see a show that's
what I tried to do from time oh yeah no
I great job my wife calls it when I
become a white yeah I try to become a
writer yeah well I try to write jokes
like like all the great writers that's
where I fail they're letting us say that
ain't us they want us to go up to him be
what's in our hearts what's in our soul
and you know what I have a bet you're
not gonna agree with yeah but that's
what comedies about I'm Tommy is my how
my world collides with the real hmm that
should come out of your mouth what's
going on in the real world and what's
going on in my world like when your mind
those poor Filipinos poor Thai kids were
in there stuck in my mind that coaches
said dusky he was gonna take him to hey
[ __ ] him in the ass and kill that
[ __ ] he was gonna figure out
what to do with the bicycles he hadn't
yet he was a how to hide scary bird
scooter well he took the Apostles down
to a cave we think what he's gonna look
at a cave well it's in a cave a back
[ __ ] those kids it took Marines to get
him out of there he he was gonna [ __ ]
those kids are leaving down there 2,000
years from now some [ __ ] guy who's
gonna find 12 little [ __ ] Thai kids
skeletons and all their [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
yet a Penn State University their
universe key jr. that's [ __ ] up that's
what we see that's what comedy is right
no stop letting Tommy you don't saying
yeah the political sound circle nothing
funny it's not fluff dad it's dead it's
a calm if you go up there with a
political joke I don't want a you know
more because that's the first thing I
see ever lose the first 10 minutes yeah
and it's just I've never hated a second
it's hatred it's pure hatred I don't
want to be a part of that at all I don't
need them at all I don't want to be poor
I'm so happy I'm a felon yeah I can't
tell you how happy I'm a felon I'm not
responsible for another this year I will
never vote I don't want to be
I'm a happen so hilarious I got a gun
yeah just plant the one at the car I
love that Oh in case things that used to
be mine I used to just get you've got to
go any I repeat we have a gun control I
get your gun ten minutes I go down to
any handbook for yeah you look a little
guy that looks poor to recover Jewish
you call him over he's got a twenty two
that don't miss and you know buy it back
after you kill him he's like a walking
point shot tell them what you did the
true listen I shot three guys with this
they didn't miss I shot one guy in the
head he'll buy it right back would you
pay would you give me 50 I'll give you
48 yeah I know take the gun back cause
you just can't get caught with that gun
you'll be charged of 18 murders I got
that gun in a baggie behind the foot I
got a gun with a silencer oh I love it
in my own building an old-school
solitaire I got a little greasy from
time to time [ __ ] fish dude I wanna
hide some guns bro that's a great try to
find some hot Goods and just start the
[ __ ] high I love that just in case
people get [ __ ] froggy at the store
you need a couple of them I'm trying to
get oh my god I watched that [ __ ]
thing the other than an ad about the
making a Scarface mmm Tina oh [ __ ] and
how about that scene with the end to
three weeks the first world when they
got there to set one on fire like they
had the worst luck in the world with
that move really it was supposed to be a
two-month shooting it ended up being a
10 month shoot where they shooting at
they shot half in Miami in the Cubist
room out then they finished it up here
by the four or five like the mother's
house is by the airport and all that
[ __ ] the tent city
yeah his web for four or five by where
they shot heat that's ten city but they
were they shot the last scene and they
that machine gun he had is like
something like a [ __ ] monster
mm-hmm so they had to figure out how to
get the gunfire they come up on the
screen and they showed all that shipment
what they didn't tell you is that the
the rounds were hot at one time Al
Pacino fell on the rounds and the bird
is like through the third-degree burn so
they had to cancel the movie again for
two weeks they had to shoot all the
after the Colombians getting shot ah
[ __ ] brilliant [ __ ] then they got an
X rating oh and they said they couldn't
put in theaters couldn't put in
Peters and then they had a fight that's
ready and then they released the movie
as a Christmas movie
no Scarface came out can you check and
see what was the release it was a
theatrical people will go into the
movies and go okay the [ __ ] Rudolph's
been doing coke breath [ __ ] Blitzen
just bought an Eightball do you remember
the little guy that's a comedian that
was in there December 9th 1983 Jesus
and I remember imagine I saw the
commercial I was living in Aspen and it
didn't reach up there like they had
gotten like they were talking
ALPA Chino said that one at the premiere
mm-hmm for the critics mm-hmm that they
started walking out that 30 minute mark
like in chunks and he just kept sinking
in his chair from the embarrassment like
he thought it was gonna bomb yeah it was
a bomb it's like people were like
[ __ ] attacking him Brian De Palma
Universal saying it was the worst thing
they've ever seen in their life the
hottest show is dynasty or something oh
wow he showed up oh really Toria
whatever of the real pretty woman and
they interviewed me they said what do
you think of the movie she goes well and
I left at the hundred [ __ ] I think 100
[ __ ] is enough for a person in a
lifetime there was 4400 [ __ ] in that
movie oh my god they counted them 4400
[ __ ] they could play that at a wedding
I felt like then what happened was the
movie bomb but the VCR
it came on in February and it just blew
a little movie and now the movies in the
top 10 all-time sales even though the
movie ain't a bag of dicks and the
[ __ ] box Tina the box office
once it hit DVR I just I still remember
going to a friend of Mines house did you
see the theater on the DVR for the VCR
for brother I the movie came out
December 9th 83 I was living in Aspen I
got off the plane
February 1st 1984 and as I got into my
buddy's car he looked at me he goes have
you seen Scarface yet and I don't know I
saw the commercial who were right to
this movie theater in Secaucus called
Harmon Cole's right there right by the
Newark Airport like 20 minutes from
Lewis Wow I didn't go home I didn't load
it was the matinee
it was like the two o'clock movie Wow
would even sit together was sold out we
couldn't even sit together it was that
sold out and at that time it was picking
up momentum it was February and it
started picking up momentum and then I
went it just came out of VCR
I still remember like Theo you would
call me and go come on Friday we're
picking up for eight-balls I'm gonna
have a case of booze when you sit there
from Friday night at 11:00 after Miami
Vice hmm
we would go out at the Miami Vice and
then go back to your house about two
three broads and we would snort coke and
watch Scarface and Godfather to the
whole weekend damn and just what every
time they do a line we'd do a line Wow
like that type of [ __ ] I just [ __ ] is
making my dick wet oh yeah the good old
days but you can't do that [ __ ] no more
thank God thank God look at your life
has changed yeah completely different
person you don't have the social issues
you had anymore that's Turk there was
all the drugs see now I have the social
anxiety I get the social anxiety when I
go to the store well it's been a lot
better lately has it been yeah do you um
when you think about all this work there
was one thing I was just oh do you
remember angel Salazar to give or work
with him all the time one of my idols
one of the guys that helped me the most
I bumped into Angel and Angel Salazar
people don't know he was uh chichi yeah
Pacino met him at the the thing 1993 I'm
a struggling comic I'm confused about
Tommy I don't know nothing about comedy
I'm just telling people I'm a comedian
getting up on stage I'm just dying
bombing dicks and I go into Hell's
Kitchen to cop a bag of coke mm-hmm
because I was working on uh I was
working on 57th and like 12th Avenue I
was selling cars and a Jeep place okay
and I would from their own walk through
Hell's Kitchen and go to Port Authority
and one day it's like July of 93 and I'm
walking through Hell's Kitchen and who
do I see in front of a building but
angel Salazar Wow and
this time I knew he was a stand-up I
knew he was a Comedy Store guy any been
in Scarface I had been in Scarface or
now and he was Cuban yeah and I went up
to him I'm like I'm CUBAN I want to be
economic and he shook my hand he took
the time to be my friend and he gave me
a a fly to come see his show and I went
and I was blown away and then he got me
an audition for an improv troupe at the
Copacabana and I just ate it back I've
been paying like $15 to heart and I had
my 13 in quarters and going in there and
they're like give us three
impersonations and me like make him
believe him but two of them were
yourself always like us
I was just horrible I had no idea I
would call him and ask for advice from
the time he would give me a little
advice from time to time that I started
working with him
and he is only all-time pisser's I mean
he is really a cocaine sack cowboy yeah
he's one of the only people that went on
the church into the package in front of
me and Lee's face turned [ __ ] red Wow
that's the only way I can get him on the
podcast if I got high we came to town he
was staying with Steven Bauer
uh-huh manolo its Garth oh yeah he stays
with him when he comes to town and then
it's right by the office they're right
by the office you know when you come to
my party yeah you could throw a rock to
where Steven Bauer lives Wow so I had
the only way I saw angel at the store
and he's like poop in your pocket as
burrow so I can call him he's hard to
wake up in the morning yeah so we had to
do it like a 10 o'clock at night and I
had to get coke from like an old coke
dealer that I knew was [ __ ] coke from
the 70s yeah some good stuff that's how
I got him in there and he would go off
camera and do little bumps and leak kept
looking at me like like we that's it
that was likely second year in the Congo
and the podcast business but the funny
is ain't I mean I have a thousand angels
I mean we used to work on old Paso bro I
came in a dealers was knocking on the
door everybody wants to give that guy
blow it is you think that part of that
kind of like like sometimes you live you
have to leave become a role
no no he'll he he'll tell you it's it's
crazy he's got laid form it I mean he's
oh yeah
it's never stop one of the funniest
stories I've heard was he did Rochester
a couple years ago hmm and in the or
yeah the right I love it up there
like Columbus I love Rochester bruh that
little walk brother wheeze I'm there the
radio eases the best brother wheeze is
the best and here he did the early show
Saturday and then he told him that he
was going to take a nap in between shows
mm-hmm and they knock the door nothing
they knock nothing they kick the door
down angels passed out he's bleeding
from his nose they get him up they
finally gave him coffee and he went up
Danny bombed and then he passed out
again they put him to this in his car
and left him there he kept saying that
they roofied me man hello
it's opening line is how long where's my
Spanish people where is my Colombia hey
girl he always go where's my Puerto
Ricans where's my Dominicans where's my
Colombians I want to talk to you later
once they said that raised a hand that
Colombian he'd say I want to talk to you
later bro we used to get [ __ ] up the
rumor is he don't even sleep he just
hangs misclassified down on the road
when he comes in like we would were
called passer together yeah first thing
he does is he shuts all the windows it's
a little fall on the glass you know I
mean he means business damn he'll go all
five nights like I haven't worked with
him now it's got to be 12 years it's a
hawk dude that the thing I hated about
doing drugs man you know what's so funny
is last night manna you know my thing
now sometimes if I get lonely by myself
and stuff I'm by myself I'll end up
watching pornography or something you
know and I'll shut the blinds this chick
is like jerking off with the [ __ ]
blinds open you know like some kind of
you know like a [ __ ] camp counselor
so I closed shop up but then this
morning I got up and you know and the
lights coming against the blinds and it
reminded me of all those times I wake up
if I was high on cocaine it because
you've been up all night so you wake up
it's like [ __ ] noon and the blinds
are closed and the
[ __ ] lights just like and just I
hated that man I hated waking up with my
blinds I like to have my blinds and my
living room and stuff open now so it's
like I wake up the day's right there
meet me in the living room you know it's
like I hated those days when everything
was like you were hiding all day you
banking people for Gatorade on the
Internet bring over some Gatorade it's
like I don't know how I can know you
trying to meet [ __ ] on tinder just to
get him to bring Gatorade over bro it's
crazy how cocaine and Tommy could go
hand-in-hand you know and I'm doing
comedy 27 years 28 years I haven't done
coke in 11 years this year that meant
for 17 years I felt like I cheated on
Tom yeah it was the weirdest thing
because I would never do it before I
want to stay but it would be in my
pocket burning a hole yeah and I would
go right from the original room people
be hey great say yeah good right I would
go right to the bathroom me tooth and do
two bamaca then it'd be all okay yeah if
I'd love the spot I wouldn't do it yeah
I would do it I would have that Coke
that Coke had me in my pocket or the
clock well I would fall apart at the
seams
yeah put in my little drug pocket yeah
and it would stay there unbothered a
little baggy waterproof in case the
[ __ ] rain came because the floods
came got biblical still in case
Louisiana all over again I'm gonna tie a
float way with [ __ ] up New York up
dude out great with every year on the
news they're like showing you yours down
there doing coke in the helicopter like
how many videos are there of the news
during a Katrina for this is a bunch of
brothers just blow in a [ __ ] blunt if
I can't getin put it on and just yelling
up you can't stop me
who the [ __ ] would even have a boy that
was terrible it's gonna happen again
yeah you know like this year
thunderstorms are getting stronger well
I think Mother Nature doesn't like some
of the stuff that we got going on
sometimes I don't think she likes some
of the energy and look she's a [ __ ]
tough lady she's a hard-working woman
missional corrected when she needs to
you know it's wild bro you know but yeah
I'm so grateful for you man for you know
and some of me you know I'm just
appreciate you always being cool with me
and be a supportive bra how can i you
know my father's from Nicaragua you know
that yeah yeah yeah oh yeah it's um
before them [ __ ] don't never give a
[ __ ] no [ __ ] on social security and
everything Spanish people don't [ __ ] I'm
sorry security I don't give a [ __ ] we
get 128 a month we'll make it work
I'll take care of you do what if one day
what if I could learn Spanish okay okay
and maybe five eight years from now we
did like a Central American tour like a
fundraiser or something down there would
you do what you think well I got no
passport oh yeah I can't stir the
[ __ ] pot man I got a lot of skeletons
in that class oh yeah and that passport
closet there's a lot of skeletons where
I get drunk pissed off I got in I'm good
I don't leave to go anywhere that's
great you want to know the [ __ ]
England that's great I can't do [ __ ] but
it's good that you learn Spanish anyway
yeah I want to learn that you learn a
language my dad talking all the time
when I was young man I loved hearing him
talk it the only language it don't help
youse [ __ ] lat but you think that if
you're a genius if you're gonna be like
I'm engineer or something like that yeah
but just you know it's like when you
become an attorney I was telling Rogan
if you go to UCLA tomorrow I want to
become an attorney a lot of your
prerequisite is math because they're
teaching honest our problems right so
you're gonna go one by one in all this
[ __ ] math well I'm gonna get into law
so yeah you're a history major but you
don't have to do a ton of math work
because it just adds up to that [ __ ]
yeah no it's good I mean it's like yeah
I think about Latin sometimes it helping
Justin to kind of know words immediately
you know when I first started out in
college I wanted to do Latin and do all
of this [ __ ] and then like halfway and I
[ __ ] thought I was gonna be I was I
got a job as a busboy in Tucson and I
thought was gonna be the best [ __ ]
busboy in a world that was my goal at
one point it's like I'm gonna be the bet
I'm gonna be busting in [ __ ] London
bussing tables like I had these dreams
like are you serious you're a busboy -
so yeah yeah dude I still live my mom
used to live out off of Golf Links off
like on East Pantano like way out there
on the east side Tucson Arizona yeah cuz
I went to college that wasn't like all
this other guys say I'm fine it's not
his foxes in his name is it no no
fella cuz they had a guy Fox a stork
rocket [ __ ] kidnap that dude but he
was also kind of cool to Tucson used to
have one of the craziest commie rooms of
all time was called Bugsy's yeah on
Tuesday nights you had him a bug to get
in nah
yeah a real bug I used to book the roof
if you showed up with a bug - the chief
- free oh my god the guy that ran the
place had to wait nine hundred pounds
yeah like eight next but yet cocaine
yeah that would make you go [ __ ]
blind that was all quarter-sawed his
neck from doing coke it was hilarious he
had the best coke in the world and I
loved that it was 150 for the night and
there was three comics we all got paid
the same hmm guess who I remember going
down there with like my second a third
time and he got the virgin eyes Mencia
fluffy really that's how young Gabriel
was Wow
we took him down and one time he came
back he was pale like man I got my dick
sucked
he was like 18th hanging out with uncle
joey's
that's the south west used to have the
seats that would face you oh yeah blows
and that was so much fun what happened
at at what a will happen I went to
Chicago
like in 2001 and that's when the the
breath strips were out with the th so
yeah so they would stick together and
one day in a burette strip and I thought
it was one but it was like nine of him
and I got on that plane that that's when
they had a direct flight from Chicago to
Burbank mmm did you know that one time
Southwest had a [ __ ] I know was I'm lyin
to you it went from Chicago back to
Vegas to Chicago you work a club on the
south side they wouldn't land that oh
hey I wouldn't land that the main
Chicago at boy it wasn't Midway Midway
yeah so you could go from Burbank
what the [ __ ] story was a little
Southwest you're gonna go there Gabriel
you said Gabriel you took a wine there's
always a balance that could be your next
vessel I took one it was nine it was hit
me Gabe it was like me Gabe my moreno
and I'd be like eight Tom if you brought
in for this little festival yeah this
club's not even opened on what was on
the south side tremendous across from
the White Castle next to a stake the
Sheikh we used to get [ __ ] stone
and I remember getting on the plane and
eating the edible and it was me like
Martin and Gabriel and we were sitting
across from tree like old women and all
sudden he had a bull started hitting me
right mm-hmm I'm 380 I'm [ __ ] huge
really it must be miserable I had to be
380 I can't you went to jail ain't yet
to live in that body that's [ __ ] when
I was to jail I wasn't I was in good
shape yeah it was one this is like 10
years ago 15 I'm gonna forget taking my
shirt off and the sweat was pouring down
me and these little old ladies we're
just looking at the floor and there I am
[ __ ] sweating another time I went to
Delphi on the red-eye and I took a
header book
like I saw hungry in a pack of cinnamon
certs that's a mistake dog don't ever
eat a pack of cinnamon searched the
whole thing cinnamon makes you sweat
like a [ __ ] nearly dog I started
sweating on a plane there was a little
gay guy next to me and he had blue
lenses and he was asleep ok people those
little things on their eyes I had to
take my shirt off there I am the first
class with the blanket up to my stomach
my tits are out
yeah you could feel the beads I remember
getting off the plane in Miami next
morning my pants were [ __ ] wet and
the waitress the stewardess was just
walking the halls look at me and give me
a water
you know how [ __ ] up I was dude
my buddy and his brother used to get so
[ __ ] up on coke in Miami then they'd
go to the hotel room put on diapers bra
cuz they kept [ __ ] themselves and
just go back down to the [ __ ] dance
floor just partying with diapers full of
[ __ ] brothers dancing and they could
dance bro
I mean these boys could [ __ ] dang it
he was a dancer smells like [ __ ]
but I think they stopped moving that
[ __ ] Bryce who get caught up with
advance what it's like to be I think
they were Latinos for sure to get coked
up with a dude that used to put a string
on his wrist mm-hmm and the string would
go to the doorknob so if he tried to
open the door knob his string Bryce
again I would some crazy people yeah I
used to get high with his brother who
was bald
and his brother would be talking to him
like we'd be doing cocaine yeah yeah and
also he'd go
like what he go and he smacked himself
because he kept thinking flies went on
his head he would smack himself 80
[ __ ] times a night and and we would
laugh at every [ __ ] time
and back he'd smack himself ego bro he
used to put balloons he lived on the
34th floor I had another friend Kurt
he's led now rest in peace good good
dude he used to get so paranoid that he
would put a little parachutes on his
cocaine sat the cop came he would throw
it out the window and little parachutes
for flopping that's the [ __ ] that was
the eighties you know God a DS is good
bro craziness how that [ __ ] just took
over everything was so much fun back
then I feel like I fell like it there
was so much more mystery and intrigue
like when I was growing up then there is
now like now there's not a lot of ton of
room for like even your imagination
because everything is you don't have to
wonder anything there's no like back in
a day a rumor like the rumor was one of
the most popular forms of like
information you know like I remember
rumors was I the rumor that Richard Gere
got caught with a mouse in his ass yeah
the San Francisco yeah years like I
never like my friend was a surgeon yeah
he was on the dog he cut his ass open
the area but I remember dude I would
start [ __ ] I remember going on camping
trips and we the day we would leave I be
like you know Jay Leno died nobody like
no [ __ ] way
and we'd be out in the woods for a week
and everybody would think that Jay Leno
died and I knew he didn't do it and we
would have these [ __ ] things and we
talked stamp at night talking about you
know the Tonight Show and [ __ ] like that
and then they get back you me like he
wasn't dead and I remember feeling like
that's psychotic to do that my Chuck
Liddell was the king of the world
yeah one day Eddie Bravo with Dana White
you know and he brought was a big Fidel
Castro fan is he really
yeah do Fidel came and spoke to me one
time I went to Cuba once good he reacted
what [ __ ] Fidel died I called him up
like Oh Eddie you know Fidel died he
thought I settled it down he looks at
Dana while he was checked with those
dead I'll call you back
what did you go to Cuba I was a student
we went there and then they had like a
big thing at the at the University in
Havana and and then Fidel chemists poked
over to our students just to our group
it was like five hours they had this
thing we had to listen to so we could
hear what was going on he was
interpreted that [ __ ] think horsemeat
in the other room people in their
[ __ ] getting a little bit of cut a
horse and a [ __ ] putting in her job
people are outside just partying a drink
and they served alcohol at it and they
had an interpreter yeah and he just
basically just told us how great
basically a lot of numbers about how
good Cuba was you know it's like
literally four four hours he spoke he
wouldn't shut up was like giving wine of
coke yeah you could never shut that
[ __ ] up you know on Sundays he
would hold like these things and he
would talk for eight hours about the
numbers of the country yeah what's going
on what's going on in Russia was going
on the United States he's very
intelligent
yeah I'd have to sit there and applaud
yeah really yeah you have to sit there
lord yeah the balcony was all cute I'd
say be watching you should to make sure
that York
it was fun man we had so much fun in the
city man we went to a baseball game and
what else did we do we just oh Harmer we
walking around just hanging out you know
drinking up you know how on a cloud you
know or whatever you know people what
use this this is 2002 so just walking
around and uh so there's some people
hanging out in an alley that are kind of
dancing and partying a little bit so we
go there and we think it's like a family
it's like a birthday cake and stuff so
we're singing you know cumpleanos
everybody's having a nice time we think
oh we're you know we're in a different
country we're celebrating some guy's
birthday then one of the dudes that the
birthday starts eating this lady out
[ __ ] just went like this and they're
like oh these are these are escorts like
we didn't know we thought it was like a
family and next thing we're all dancing
with these [ __ ] ladies and she
everything it's like a grandmother like
a [ __ ] birthday party yeah well you
guys goes down where the ladies waste a
little low and plug in and starts eating
her [ __ ] right they're like what oh
[ __ ] welcome to Cuba
yeah awesome I was talking about me last
weekend I went to a party and there was
boats and next
you know there was a girl [ __ ] a guy
in the boat I didn't know what to do get
in there let somebody get that dick suck
at least go put a finger in there at
least cheer for you know my buddy we got
some calls and stuff that came in Joe
you mind if we jump to a couple of them
we got some calls and questions that
came in let's hit some of the UH you
know did some fan lines that came in
these some live Ray's fan lines that
came in
hey guys Luke a contact you from Spain
Joey I'd reckon Thea would handle
himself in the streets of New Jersey
when you were growing up how do you
think he'd do not saying he's a [ __ ] or
anything but he doesn't seem to be
dealing with those footers over firing
the kid very well what was the question
he said how do you think deal would do
in the streets of New Jersey when you
were growing up and you can be honest
perfectly cuz you had a sense of humor
oh wow you either have to be tougher you
had to be funny I wasn't tough I was
funny yeah I like this and I had a heart
and balls like it steel so they left me
alone I think I cover
I could definitely check at least three
of those boxes you can make somebody
laugh yeah people love that people love
that [ __ ] dude that's one of the things
that always I feel like acclimated like
when it was easy for me to acclimate
sometimes around black culture in my
area because you know a lot of us were
on the same kind of financial level you
know they had more like generational you
know deficit I think cuz just you know
generation after generation of being
black and the South was like really
tough just tough maybe tough being black
anyway I came from Cuba I learned about
did they have black people there in Cuba
yeah so black people weren't invented oh
wow you know I mean look at kapha Cuba
half of my car
yeah they got that more than half that
look like Julius Erving yeah because
they were brought over with the slaves
and then mixed into the into the culture
yeah when you when you're Cuban when you
take a DNA test you're not gonna like
the results if you're white you don't
really don't like the results but I know
the results because I grew up there and
all the people you know my uncle my mom
was like you but her brother has kinky
hair and it's like cat blood yeah I have
two cats of the Siamese they're brothers
one looks like a Siamese yeah it was a
Lepus yeah cuz every eight generations
that leopard blood comes out with the
spots Wow you know my other sister my
sister same mother the same father
my sister's dark really yeah my son
that's beautiful that calls they have
the band in Cuba at me and aqui Alfonso
and me the sister is dark icky who was
on Anthony Bourdain when he goes to Cuba
cuz he owns a bar with nocturia uh-huh
he's light-skinned so now Cubans are
very racist are they really oh and is it
against the skin tone or is it against
the skin tone that's why if you watch
like if you ever go on Netflix this is
show called celeea I must Elliott Cruz
it's brilliant because it shows you Cuba
in the 40s like when they told you a
little too dark to be singing Wow then
she started singing and the guy was like
whoa wait a second they're like we're a
little too much they listen yeah yeah
you know it's really interesting when
you watch that show about how
homosexuality mm-hmm that [ __ ] didn't
fly in Cuba oh wow yeah what they have
the best homos well that's what I'm
saying but it didn't fly like they
killed the brother they didn't they
never let you know what happened to her
brother but they killed him hmm and I
know as a kid I had an uncle that would
tell me that if you were gank you were
your parents to take you shark fishing
and I'm off the boat like it was
Cuba's a rough [ __ ] place like I've
met Cubans in Pasadena so I brought
Cuban afro-cuban music to the house and
they might take it off hmm
we can handle it they know they have the
black blood in them they don't want to
be reminded oh wow
me I use it to my advantage yeah who I
am
you know if it wasn't for Richard Pryor
I wouldn't be I love Julio serving I
would be it wasn't for Redd Foxx I
wouldn't be if it was if Al Green I
wouldn't be here you know these are all
part of people who make my comedy right
straight-up gangster you know yeah
Julius Erving is what I do on stage I
take it to the hoop we ain't got no time
to [ __ ] around with slam dunking on your
[ __ ] ass I remember you told me
there's a great eye and I watched it too
there's a great all-star game where him
and Pistol Pete played together still
Pete was the best that was my dog that
was that was when he played black yeah
that was the thing
pistol' yeah he was the first why I got
to play black to play black with a white
mind but black the dribbly yeah it
wasn't fast I mean he asked him look up
he'll run the 40 in two days yeah took
him two days together bring lunch you
got to bring wine because he used black
body movements to shake you ya hear that
white hey he had a shake and the dribble
there's a scene when he sees Julius
Erving and he fakes to bob mackadoo
and he just flips it behind his back
that was his [ __ ] yeah so when that
all-star game they just made a mistake
they put a white dude they put a black
dude that was dressed up as a white dude
NBA yeah and he just [ __ ] them up he
just it was his game you know if any and
if you watch it he only had four assists
I read that the Box course of that but
watch what he was doing that game
beautiful Pistol Pete oh yeah blacken it
up yeah that's that black culture that's
half of what I got I can't that's why I
can never be read half of what I do is
black a little bit of Chinese a little
bit of Santeria yeah a little bit is
[ __ ] Jewish I'm a [ __ ] dog you're
[ __ ] nine percent Halloween yeah and
I do doubles man are you with a soccer
flower how the devil's night Pat that
[ __ ] Halloween's for [ __ ]
kids Devils mailboxes you got a [ __ ]
full moon in your [ __ ] bro yeah all
Devils that was not you supposed to stab
a [ __ ] over the next year you
got a bash that's the that's the
originals oh really oh yeah the old
school was that's when you hit somebody
in the head with a pipe wow that been
pissing you off for Devil's Night
thirty-eight Devil's Night and he candy
the next year's like Goodluck Chinese
it's like the year the [ __ ] [ __ ]
Chinese rah you know I was just in China
a dude I saw a dude pick his nose and
feed it to a [ __ ] cat bruh
and the cat ate it and it was like but
that's China you know China is like a
thing you're walking with your buddy he
dies you [ __ ] make a soup a couple
people eat in [ __ ] crews and nobody
goes nobody knows nothing and the guys
honored to die and be part I was faint
Trevor one week what do you think I
loved it man
you know but they're like
they are a forward-moving place like you
can't get citizenship there as a you
know like nobody's coming into China
like China doing their take they're
ready to take over the world but not in
like a [ __ ] up way like I don't think
they're it doesn't seem like the people
are thinking about in a military sense
they're just like we are Chinese
we are proud you know we just keep
moving forward you need something built
right there we'll [ __ ] build it we'll
build it a hundred stories high
you know it doesn't matter like we'll
die nine times will be reincarnate
whatever we got to do to just keep it
moving commie how many minutes it was
keep it moving three three nights you
just went by yourself it was great yeah
we went over there and they got a group
over there called seen a Cinna
Senay productions or whatever promotions
do they do it it's great they flew me
first-class put me up all bro beautiful
places on every gonna state through some
of the moat hotels [ __ ] places so
expensive I couldn't even sleep
you know like 600 bucks I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'll stay awake and watch some
money go by you know at least enjoy to
walk around the room this thing's $600 a
[ __ ] night you know they had like
nine light switches in there there it's
like a [ __ ] I don't know where I was
it's a problem you can spend 40 minutes
just [ __ ] turning on all the lights
[ __ ] crazy it is man it gets really
interesting let's take another couple
calls if you don't mind I got a piece
and we'll take you home or get the [ __ ]
out of you got it let's do it he said oh
we with some good advice or some
suggestions I can give my wife for her
first psychedelic trip appreciate it man
love you guys
whoa it's like a living in an aquarium
you see that [ __ ] guy right there
first thing for a psychedelic trip is
for his wife for his wife just make it
easy for it but then [ __ ] with her once
she's ah yeah oh wait I I think you told
me a story about this one time yeah when
my first wife in San Francisco in 85 we
took some Grateful Dead ass and went to
a party I was very nice to her you said
her stepdad was at the airport I kept
all about don't you have to pick your
father up at the airport let's go then
she'd go what time is he coming in I
mean I had this poor girl going then
there was a poster of Bruce Lee out of
the wall and I kept going to looking at
Bruce Lee going don't say that into her
dog don't say that doors
I wouldn't look at me like what's he
saying I don't listen don't I put that
girl that's the girl that I wrote the
letter so I bet her to death
once I have we were living in San
Francisco we I was living in the Haight
Ashbury and I was just a professional
thief in the daytime I bartend the two
nights a week at Rock and Robbins yeah
but there was all these Cuban refugees
that sold nickel bags and I was the
interpreter my job was to go to John to
Japan city whatever mm-hmm and I would
pass out traveler's checks mm-hmm so
they would bring me stolen traveler's
checks and I was they couldn't do it
because they were Cuba didn't know
language right I would take a $50
traveler's check pay some four hours and
then they give me 46 and change oh wow
that's the old school and traveler's
checks you can you could if we take a
while to come back around what you do
with traveler's checks you go to the
bank at $1,000 with the traveler's
checks go to your hotel room I'll come
over kick the door down I take the
traveler's checks I give you five and
then you get another thousand cuz they
would guarantee they could all die
stolen in the old days hmm
it was a scam that so I would go to you
we go we got 520 let's go buy some
traveler's checks you have to file a
police report but then they'll give you
it was a lot easier in 85 right there's
now now they probably you gotta go give
a finger test and see DNA and but back
then there was no American Express
traveler's checks yeah I remember
hearing about this on television how
don't forget one night like we were at
this Cuban dudes house and we were still
on couch and she was sitting there with
me and this Cuban dude goes not for
nothing but your wife doesn't say much I
go she's deaf huh
she wasn't deaf she just didn't speak
Spanish oh yeah so a guy looks at me
goes he's all coked up he's like I don't
know if you know this I work with deaf
people in Cuba right oh right look she's
like I'm like talk to her and death
language and he's like and he's doing
all these noises and [ __ ] and she's like
looking at me I go she goes what am i
doing I go just draw some hang signals
then [ __ ] with him and she's like and
won't say he looks at me goes I've never
studied that laugh
[ __ ] what do you miss anything about
your first wife like was there some cool
stuff about her yes
we were kids yeah we were kids me kids
is fun we were kids we were in love you
know yeah the kid loved that young love
it's a 21 22 yeah it just went somewhere
and she grew up and I didn't that's what
happened w-why though the truth yeah she
grew up and I did I wasn't the type of
person you want to be around back that
yeah so yeah there's little things I
missed the [ __ ] was from Buffalo no
Buffalo nobody made a wing like her huh
she made wings and a walk and she made
blue cheese dressing from scratch with
Corona beer you never seen them in it
and I'd watch delirious this is way
before stand-up Tommy I'd rent videos
and watch [ __ ] and she cooked those
wings and she'd make [ __ ] thousands
of wings and [ __ ] walk she was a
great lady and she we have a great
daughter together you know I don't talk
to her but she's in my thoughts God gave
me a second chance
yeah and that's why I gotta get the [ __ ]
outta cuz I gotta go see ya we tied
smoother than the whole [ __ ] field
yeah let's happy I came down here to see
you man I fell in love with you a long
time ago and that now I'm happy because
my senses were right I picked three
winners I picked a lot of guys I picked
you I picked Kail I picked Dean Del Ray
you know you guys are hustlers you're
honest I could see that comedy store you
know it lets you see I seen a lot of
people who fake the funk up there man
yeah you see him yeah who think you
actually see people go up there that
wish we do bad you watch them the back
of the room Tommy still has a lot of
different angles it teaches you how to
be a lot of things yeah but the thing
you get the most is that the camaraderie
you and I have we couldn't have a better
comradery we came out of the same snatch
this is real yeah this is real I cheer
for you yeah saying when you came
see me do the left leg special you paid
out of your pocket you cheered for me
yeah that's something that people real
comics a lot of comics hey I love you I
love this work Shh I've listened to feel
you know you don't have to say that you
don't have to say now that doesn't mean
any yeah I know who's thinking about
yeah and I know who's the only gonna be
there temporary and I know who's gonna
be there with me to the end I know the
person who comes up to me and says at
the end bro I joke was badass I know he
means it I also know the person that
comes up and says Theo you were great on
I'm dying up here when you walk by the
like [ __ ] redneck sack of [ __ ] yeah
you know that survives at the Comedy
Store
you were great that when you walked by
he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he probably
blew somebody's [ __ ] not gonna have a
[ __ ] that's the other angle of so you
have to learn how to deal with all that
be a comic and remember be the biggest
things that's I'm a man yeah became a
comic this badass Ellen what men we got
to act like [ __ ] man yeah I think
it's one thing that I you know like that
you don't eat it you kind of covertly
like you know I think you infuse that
like you know even just hearing you tell
your stories knowing you know
recognizing you got a second chance with
some stuff with some family stuff and
like you know I that stuff is like you
know low-key like inspiring you know
because you know yes you know for me
personnel you know I live in some of
those worlds and I just feel you know
scared and nervous but you know I do
know you do mate you always made me feel
like I have a friend and that I have
somebody that cares and like you know if
I'm if I'm friends with you to the end
of my life and I would be honored you
know no this is listen man I lost God
took away my family showed me the gift
of friendship yeah and the gift of
friendship is beautiful
people just misuse it yeah miss handler
and they don't know how to handle it
yeah you have acquaintances and you have
friends and you have people you live and
breathe for I breathe for you I breathe
family I breathe the cake Quigley Joe
Rogan I'll stand in fear I will take
that bullet in the Tommy store and shoot
you 12 times you mess it Ari Shaffir you
bet I do I'll [ __ ] you
you mess with Duncan I put a bullet
that's what I'll shoot you to death you
touch red band
I will [ __ ] personally send you to
Mars I will call somebody that likes
people on fires for a living the $5,000
you Franco Frankie baby people have no
idea what it is living for some
breathing for somebody yeah everything
in this Hollywood town is he's amazing
is that you ain't [ __ ] that's why when
when the [ __ ] turns you know looking now
so for somebody accuses fear over
something and I gotta hate Theo
no that's not how it works I know Theo
20 years I'm gonna back the up right if
something happens to me in an Asian
fires me and that and I'm with that
agency and heaven I would fire that
agent yeah because they don't back their
people right that's what we don't have
anymore
and he really touch your [ __ ] prove it
and I'm still with them yeah what the
[ __ ] are you talking about yeah but we
live in a society out here that we don't
have nothing we'll only have friends as
hot as our career gets mmm if we get hot
then they talk to you I don't want you
to talk I want you to talk to me when I
was broke yeah those are the people I
talked to today the people that were my
friends when I would go up to the comics
trongo field
let me $3 so I could get a gram of coke
I got 17 did you give me three I get a
20 I give you three forever man I love
you baby two men down here I would drive
down here for anybody else yeah we
appreciate it man we got a lot of young
listeners that love you I got this hat
too man that uh buddy my maid it's from
a it's for my friends company called
hood hats but they make dope hats and
nobody else has that hat man says when
West Hollywood Comedy Store this is it
it's a one-of-a-kind I love you man
thanks coming on I love you thank you
for having me
yeah I'll see you soon
[Music]
like these I thought it's gonna take
little time for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]